hello reject nation the Craig Alva here
and I am that poppy that's as one
awesome channel doesn't need estar need
a stargazer from the neatest our channel
I just roll it up
that's right quote we're gonna watch
today my hero
one of my heroes Conan O'Brien works out
with America's female heroes the world
seeming rather
Wonder Woman's gal gadot goodness and if
anyone knows anything about gal gadot
she is sexy as hell you don't know her
acting abilities hey Rach Rocky's
ability fit and sexy
yes Conan sexy Conan is way sexier I
mean even I've heard I would do Conan
over a gal yeah I did I would have come
over any gal Wow yeah that is I'm not
onto you today hey why not
run I can see you and Conan having a
real connection like real bond
thankfully I as well you're being
offered yeah no I worth it I think you
would really make a connection I think
you'd be really comfortable with common
yeah he's tall I like calling we're
gonna be doing a patient today shout out
today for totally jumble
that'll be at the end of the video so
total jumble if you're watching stay
tuned stay tuned let's watch this I
gotta say this is exciting I am here in
a Warner Brothers soundstage and I'm
standing with the beautiful gal gadot
Wonder Woman No nice to see you applause
I know right I don't really do meet me
in a warehouse I was shocked that he
said yeah coming so and the big question
I had well how did this woman transform
herself into Wonder Woman six months
prior to the shoot I had to do a lot of
in working on that accent so far as he
sings with you roughly six months to
become the woman I don't want to select
taken as an insult but I've got about 35
minutes
that's all the time I need someone to
watch via delicate sight you're the
green to be Israeli army yeah that's
probably where it old again I was a Girl
Scout naughty with these I'll be ready
when you're about to see my body second
I'm gonna reappraise to be me tell me
what you see what are the strengths or
the weaknesses
I'm a very weak leg bigger and worse
than you should you say that I'm not
built like a man I think you'll be
shocked at what you miss can you be mad
okay especially you so you know I'm a
trainer what mr. Traynor was free to do
that
so this is your trainer and your name is
so they're done Booga yes and you work
somewhere tickling Czech Republic leg
she said there wait you obsessive
probably all right Brutus people are
going to be shocked at what I can do
yeah long my views is my long way yeah
oh do I make that could stop my legs
look like this as long as you do it
so I have some kick some catch yeah yep
huh
and we - but who - okay that's okay I
guess that's it so bend the knee then
kick that's gonna be good we want to
recoil overboiled sports bend the knee
and then kick you in the Israeli Army's
for today
exactly that's how we do in Boston
holiday okay what's next
so now you come in how do I defend
against that b-black me Ruta how do i
drop it
nothing block antenna and the same oh
but you're sure yeah I know okay
one two three amazing you looking so bad
look how I look to the camera
[Music]
and then while I'm busy doing that Ruta
we've been doing this a very short time
would you say that already I'm making
incredible progress now I'm really
getting oh yeah I love it I feel I feel
powerful but I'm ready in time never
easy yes he's laughing his back okay
thank you can luck illness with those
Tigers thing was exact a baby they can
put in in post right now they're going
to put in a full o milk
[Music]
[Applause]
and now we will see that the man
superior your fawlcon
I'll be honest I'm not feeling great
about this where you say oh but you look
great - a bit where I'd like to do if
you have just a minute I'd like to just
step off camera for a second and come
back in a way that I think Oh God yeah
comic-con yeah like it's going to get
hairy grill the realest part in the next
one do you think there was a possibility
that I could be on cameras as a possible
love interest for Wonder Woman we can
add anything yes yes again maybe just
add you saying yes okay sir anything
I could be on camera as a possible love
interest for Wonder Woman yeah it's
really any magic really it is different
something we have not mastered is horse
riding one woman great rider is great
we couldn't get a horse from the Warner
Brothers lot of course so we do have the
next best thing
this is the best we could do makes it
look like sitting on a mechanical bull
arouses me okay it's starting three days
out this name I think it's dying I mean
this feels like this has hepatitis what
a woman comes up to second will be
pretty much what you see right now oh my
god very beautiful and I don't think
you're seeing it like that we're both
married
she's hairy galaxy today look you gotta
marry her man for sure not ruined
thought I had a jamming this guy looks
like dr. house Gregory House in the
house it looks like 30 years older than
her yeah me Lori dude he looks totally
Thank You Lori
oh man well not about losing guys good
for him man it's the English looking
faster here at he and lucky bastards
calm down Gregory what a lucky bastard
oh my god jealousy's she's eating Oh
beautiful Jesus I mean he's not a
bad-looking guy I mean he's not I don't
I think it's an attractive guy a couple
of very good-looking Jews yes I just say
that young gal cannot be and in the
video gal gadot dunes like she's not
quiet yeah yeah she was a little bit you
know reserved I feel like she was vibing
off of a common synergy a little bit
yeah I mean one thing I love about Kona
is that no matter how awkward someone
may be behaving or quiet he knows how to
play out whenever he's getting so well
he's like the best that I think the
Improv term and it was like act as if
yeah and I feel like he's really good at
acting as if no matter what the
intuition is you can make whatever
materials happening work that's great
even if they're quiet and cuz they
actually see him I've seen her in
interviews that seem really dirty Sokol
but she or she seemed really quiet and
reserved she was more about the action I
feel like actually talking so she
probably didn't prepare as much before
something he understands coming to
Robert III it looks like she might have
been confused yes I am she's very
comfortable yeah she's just like I'm
just going to keep smiling
yeah that's a terrible attitude what
does it keeps my entire time well like I
said I feel like maybe when you see her
more talkative for interview she's
actually prepping for questions yeah
this she knew was like gonna be more
action so she didn't feel like probably
like she needed to prep very much for
you know yeah yeah just just what to say
and she has an accent
thick accent - so she's like English is
obviously not her first language so sure
I just have to prep a lot before
interviews and then because she's like
hang whatever just go with the flow and
then she cut it was like dude she is a
badass though she was like she's done
this heavy combat training and Israeli
line yeah badass Wonder Woman model
cookie kick your ass that is the way of
you gotta model you know best kind of
models those are the women who
intimidate me the most because my
brother has friends who are stunt woman
he's actually friends oh and Wonder
Woman stunts that would go yeah rad I am
nervous as hell when I talk to them we
pursue them on Instagram - look dan I
got Bing and cut bodies and yeah I'm a
person elected person could also kick my
ass at any moment that I talk to them
well you may just have to try narcissism
off gregorio sorry no I was going to say
you tell me that I'm going to just one
to copy when it goes like in real life
yeah but this kind of made me want to do
a fight scene again
you should do a fight scene in this cuz
I can do those kicks easily think this
tricks are easier I think you should
recruit a Tyrone okay I'm sorry
oh you would rip me to shreds
yeah you're abused resident and all the
right places I mean the ads already
nothing so yeah I mean that's one way of
ripping someone to shreds Tyrone look
and really fight he can't I don't care
okay what you people think I'm just
gonna leave the bit on that one good he
might be buffer and he might be stronger
at weightlifting and all those things I
can kick and punch you might not believe
me but I'm gonna do it I'm gonna do a
video cuz this technique next door
Fillmore said she said that's the eye
and I think I think next I'm going to be
like watch this I'm going to hire
someone who looks exactly like hi Rob oh
I'll do it
I got a slight I run out here all right
then I use a penis wine stuff he has a
million followers fly yourself longer
fly over here hangout I owe your drink
still what would you do it what I do
what Tyra oh we've already it's done
play it again I would all bye we're
doing it now actually I didn't tell you
but this is because you passed you
passed now where is he why do you want
to know good wait what he [ __ ] like a
stallion fine be with Tyrone I shall be
with me uh-huh oh my jealous how I said
all those things about Tyrone unable
affect so it doesn't why are you picking
at your skin right now anxiety who you
subscribe to the real reject subscribe
to the real reason verification belt
that notification though I need a new
star I am sorry Zack I am glad her out
there Anita hey shout-out to totally
jumbled he comments a lot he's been a
longtime follower
yeah and totally jumbled is how I'm
feeling right now with all my emotions
towards tyro Mia and Anita [ __ ] up I
mean I can say that right now my
feelings are totally jumbled yes
and they're going to come out with my
fist it's going to be the first couple I
kill and I can't wait is what happens
when you don't deal with your emotions
they get totally jumbled I'm sorry
what bad person garbage human being I'm
you're not a bad person you're a
beautiful person that's the only reason
why I'm totally jumbled right now yes we
don't know when you cry keep sleeping do
you yeah